hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to smile
challenge now it's been a while since I
did one of these and since that time
I've turned my heart into a stone-cold
ice cube of death all joy has been
purged from me in every way possible and
I have no smiles left for anybody its
hashtag smile never up in this [ __ ]
I've got a few cute and nice videos to
see here but I won't be swayed by their
adorable nature I'm a stone-cold [ __ ]
and that's what I shall stay so bring it
on ya honking dog nope no smiles here
why would there be any there's no need
for me to be here there's no need for me
to be like there's no need no need for
me to be me for me for me to be okay
there's no need for me to be here today
no one needs media today what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me no need for me here
today there's no need for me here how
could I ever have a job go in there walk
do know needs me here today
mmm nuts
trick sauce trick trick
[Laughter]
[Music]
no this one this somehow turned out to
be more of trying not to laugh than it
has try not to smile which makes it even
harder cuz they lease in to try not to
laugh I can smile a bit
maybe supposed to be not funny it's not
smile worthy it's depressing even that's
horrible
you could have killed her I'm so
concerned yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes what ye l spell yes
is s ey es oh boy good old-fashioned
social experiments that we find
beautiful wondering if we could take a
picture man thank you you ready Wow yeah
stone cold hard hard goddamn social
experiment
they look at each other
[Music]
[Applause]
my sweat from straining not a real dog
the only thing Levi ever won a not like
if I ever want to lose a competition to
cry or something like that all I got to
do is watch those videos of the dogs
that their owner has like come back from
war or something like that look that's
all I got to do i watch one of those and
I'm gone
all right so that was to try not to
smile challenge we had a bit spattering
all over the place bully
laughs and try not to cry this was like
a an experience it was good old like try
not to be human in front of all these
human experiences but either way thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you enjoyed this one I don't know how
often I'll do these types of this one
but there's another subreddit that I
want to explore that I think is gonna be
good I've got an idea for it but I'll
see that in the future so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye